for the collection but oh my whoa whoa
we got some heated exchanges going on
here Afflalo and Billy this has been
brewing for a while and Afflalo is hot
toldja bellies no Punk he had Arron
Afflalo in a headlock he was gonna break
his neck
[Applause]
and there's no question that with
hearing Afflalo and he's trying to box
him out
he faces him up and then just Oh Afflalo
were the full swing and then and here
belly's gut he's gonna break his neck
right here he got him in a headlock like
he's his little brother right here as a
real cheap shot by Afflalo though that's
a punk move right there that is gonna be
a hefty fine and a lengthy suspension
see if we can see where it happened
[Applause]
tangle up reveal its it took a swing at
it not sure if he connected there's
something going on fryer here is
[Applause]
DJ Augustine Kim Bertram s-21 do trying
to break things up Frank Vogel
Jade Hernandez assistant coaches out on
the floor Corliss Williamson big nasty
doing his job keeping the players